hey Mary here once again to talk to you
about the latest games coming out this
week in new releases and this week
surprise you get the wolf among us
episode 2 now if you don't get this
episode right away you're gonna have as
hard of a time avoiding spoilers as if
you were to miss an episode of Game of
Thrones don't you think we ought to do
something about it I pick it up pretty
fast don't miss it februari for this
week the game inspired by the movie
inspired by the game inspired by the toy
comes to fruition in the lego movie
videogame experience a world where
superheroes are real and you are they're
fearless but inept leader but don't
worry lots of terrible leaders seem to
work out just fine I stand behind my
decision this press conference is over I
can't see you now I can't hear you now
you're not here not play the game before
you see the movie februari 7th also this
week the notorious RPG is back to
celebrate its 10th birthday with fable
anniversary coming to xbox 360 to remind
us of why we fell in love with Albion in
the first place experience the gorgeous
environments enemies and comrades like
never before remember the decisions to
kill or spare lives but mostly relive
the touching story and humor as it
always was that way yeah great big
battles are in turn fable and the lost
chapters are available februari for but
if you are really hoping to pee your
pants this week consider picking up
outlast which is now making its way to
ps4 as miles Upshur a freelance
journalist and noted scaredy cat you're
tasked was staying alive within an
asylum crawling with escaped inmates
miles has nothing but his solid
hide-and-seek skills and a camera with
the worst batteries in the world to keep
him going turn out the lights februari
fifth
this week also gives us bravely default
a turn-based RPG in the style of classic
Final Fantasy games featuring a robust
job system and unique social mechanics
through the 3ds StreetPass the white
mage the black mage and the month would
be the first jobs game early on but a
total of 24 jobs can be obtained
throughout the game starts talking BP
February seventh also this week you can
get your hands on the self-proclaimed
best grapefruit simulator that money can
buy offering a cast of over 360,000
polygons five percent of your daily
vitamin c intake and at least six jokes
consider putting this wacky weird
interactive quote-unquote game on your
radar yes this is actually the trailer a
game comes out februari seventh and
finally i couldn't let you go without
mentioning that dust horse is coming to
Vita PSN and xbox februari for the ninja
janitors go around sweeping walls clean
but don't let the fact that someone beat
this game blindfolded fool you this game
is no joke this is absolutely a hardcore
platformer so if it's a bit too intense
for your liking pick it up anyway
because you can listen to music by life
formed for further details visit
gamespot's new releases page release
dates are based on retailer listings and
are subject to change see you next week
you